I tried to capture
like in the 60s I'm thinking incense and
modris bed spreads and I mean like I
that's what I'm thinking of and then Teo
who makes the makes mixes all of the
perfume he could take what I was
thinking and what I what I was hoping
into the studio and then and make it so
and it took forever it took forever
I was shocked that 70s didn't smell like
marijuana I'm just gonna be honest with
you up front
I was like oh this one will obviously
smell like Willie Nelson's bus right um
but no it's it smells like and Willie
Nelson's Quest it smells exactly like
marijuana
I I went on Willie Nelson's bus once and
I got a contact on I was I couldn't
believe it I like these it was a
terrible old buzz but like everybody had
it it was yeah it was a terrible little
buzz but he was great and and just
drugs everywhere
wasn't it was laid out on the table it
was so amazing it was like you it was
like as if you go into a store like some
old school Airstream in LA and that's
the store in La where they're selling it
was like it was everything you kind of
wanted it to be when you walked in but
then when you walked out you were
definitely hungry right
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]